and joining us in the studio to talk a
little bit more about the state of
research in Africa is an expert from the
German African Business Association
Laura Peterson welcome to tomorrow today
now we just saw an excellent example of
how researchers are pursuing important
work in Africa but I think the general
impression in Europe is that not much is
happening there when it comes to
research is that is that fair is that a
fair assessment well there are quite a
few projects like the one we've just
seen but in general the scientific
output of Africa is only 2% compared to
the rest of the world which is if you
look at the size of Africa of course way
too little well why aren't there more
you know not that many groundbreaking
results why aren't there more well it's
like a financing mostly and of course
lack of that goes with it a lack of
scientists the African Union decided to
spend 1 percent of GDP on science and an
education and most countries are
actually quite far from that still
mm-hmm so it's not actually very much
money and even those obligations aren't
being fulfilled but many countries have
fundamental problems than in Africa with
education and with poverty on our
Facebook page one viewer called poverty
a dream killer are there maybe simple
ways to promote grassroots research and
education in these countries well there
are a few projects that are working on
solving African problems for example
McCreery University in Kampala is
working on applications for smartphones
in agriculture and on solar farms so
they're different yeah they're different
projects trying to promote grassroots
development but of course you also have
to look at what the what the economy
needs and they don't necessarily need
scientists but mechanics and people in
the skilled trades perhaps exactly if
you are young if you are a young African
scientist or mathematician
where would you go in Africa up until
now many have have left to go to the EU
or to go to America where would you go
if you wanted to focus on maybe
fundamental research
there are quite a few research
institutions in South Africa of course
then in the north of Africa and more and
more coming up in Kenya Nigeria Ghana so
there are already a few hubs where
scientific projects are connected going
on what I mean a major problem is as the
jobs market isn't it I mean there's miss
it there's missing the in-depth we're
missing the industrial side of thing all
of these educated young people are
coming out of schools and universities
and they don't have there's no jobs
there they're fleeing because they're
basically for economic reasons do we
need to focus on the infrastructure
industry yeah definitely that is a huge
problem because if academics can't find
a job first of all they are leaving and
then all the money that was put into
their education has some gone out of the
window well quite a few are coming back
now so it's not completely wasted but
what what areas what are the exciting
areas in Africa where that kind of
infrastructure building is going on
there are like lots of investments from
well from China of course but also from
Germany and our companies are always
complaining that they can't find proper
workers that that I advocated in
engineers for example well one of their
is would for example be infrastructure
or the energy sector of course that's
that's that's a place where everybody is
investing at the moment that I paid us
and thanks very much for joining us on
the show thank you